hey out there welcome welcome into
another edition of Market takes man it's
it's a great day for financial news a
great day I appreciate you tuning in I
know you could have been anywhere in the
world but you are here with me right
here on Market takes I am Dion Rabon
reporter at the Wall Street Journal
before we dive into our usual look ahead
at what's going on this week we've got
to take a second step back and talk
about what's going on with First
Republic Bank the sale the J.P Morgan
Chase we will be breaking all that down
talking about how that could affect the
markets going forward and and what to
watch out for next but of course as
always not only will we be talking about
First Republic and what happened today
I'll be breaking down the three biggest
things you need to watch out for this
week now this week in addition to First
Republic coming up we have the fed's May
meeting this is a huge week the FED
meets on May or I'm sorry on May 2nd and
3rd we will hear from Fed chair Jerome
Powell on Wednesday we will talk through
that we we also get the jobs report on
Friday but in addition to the jobs
report there are two other big reports
coming out this week about the labor
market that you'll want to tune into and
third we get apple Berkshire Hathaway
Pepsi Pfizer BP Airbus and many many
more this is the biggest earnings week
thus far for the first quarter period we
are going to break down what you need to
watch and what matters so we will get
into all of that but first let's take a
second step back and talk about First
Republic and what happens now this is
the second biggest bank failure in U.S
history you're talking about a bank that
had nearly 200 billion dollars in
deposits just about a quarter ago a
little over a quarter go at the end of
2022 that has been seized it was seized
by the FDIC the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation and sold to J.P
Morgan Chase JPM assuming all the first
republics 92 billion dollars remaining
in deposits also buying most of the
bank's assets including 173 billion
dollars in loans 30 billion dollars in
security the FDIC hit that's the
taxpayer is going to be 13 billion
dollars from its Insurance Fund the FDIC
has Insurance Fund for just these sorts
of things JPMorgan also said it will
receive 50 billion dollars in financing
from FDIC this is the second largest
failure after if you all remember
Washington Mutual back in 2008 that was
the largest this is bigger than Silicon
Valley Bank bigger than signature this
was the nation's 14th largest bank uh
this is big news uh interesting to note
JPMorgan also is the bank that took over
Washington Mutual so now JP Morgan is
the buyer or the company taking over the
number one and number two largest bank
failures in the history of the U.S so
really quickly how did we get here well
listen most recently you guys have seen
what happened with Silicon Valley Bank
Signature Bank just this Rush of
deposits out the door well investors
found out first Republic lost about a
hundred billion dollars in deposits in a
March run on the bank following its
earnings reports that just came out last
week now the bank stock lost almost 50
percent of its value in one day that was
just investors saying we have no
confidence that after this 100 billion
dollars in deposits went out the door
this bank can still hold up the bank had
taken only had taken on about 30 billion
dollars in deposits from the big five
that's a U.S bank Wells Fargo JP Morgan
which now owns the bank uh Citigroup and
and those guys those big names but they
were unable to sell or put a deal
together before they reported earnings
and once they reported that hundred
billion dollar loss man the Wolves were
in the stock was sold out and this was a
huge huge loss you had a collection of
uninsured deposits now if you've seen
the run on these Banks what we saw and
what we have seen is just a a run on the
banks from the biggest from the banks
with the most uh uninsured deposits
uninsured deposits are basically
deposits that are over two hundred fifty
thousand dollars the FDIC says we're not
going to ensure that you take the risk
if you put money in a bank that's over
that amount Silicon Valley Bank had 97
percent of its deposits were uninsured
Signature Bank 90 of its deposits First
Republic 68 so what comes next well the
next largest bank or the next bank with
the largest share of deposits uninsured
East-West Bank 67 Comerica with 64
Western Alliance 55 percent uh Pac West
52 Zion's Bank 51 key Corp 47 or Key
Bank so listen all those are are stocks
to watch out for uh keep your eye I want
to put something up here on your screen
really quickly to just kind of show you
the overall reaction now what you're
looking at right now is the year-to-date
performance of the KBW NASDAQ Bank index
now this is all the banks an ETF that
follows all the big Banks it's
Washington Mutual it's JP Morgan it's
it's Citibank but it's also some of
those Regional Banks and over the course
of year you've seen just a huge downturn
but over the last couple weeks you'd
seen a little bit of a pickup but let me
throw you to today and what we're
looking at right now you're seeing a
little bit of turmoil now First Republic
shares have been halted First Republic
is no longer trading after the seizure
and sailed to JP Morgan so it's not
hurting the overall movement of this
index but we are seeing overall down the
index is just a little bit negative for
the day but it's picking back up we're
seeing maybe some bullish as maybe
people thinking okay the worries about
the overall banking sector under are
overblown and let's you know let's not
overdo it so that just illustrating
right now the mood on the banks you're
not seeing a major sell-off right now in
terms of the overall banking index but
obviously those Bank shares a little bit
negative on the day listen what comes
next well all First Republic Bank
branches become Chase Bank branches like
I said Chase has taken on those
depositors so if you are a First
Republic Bank customer you now bank with
Chase whether you wanted to or not and
investors not really excited about the
banking sector but we're not seeing a
major sell-off like we did after svb and
signature in some of those collapses a
lot of this priced in and like I said
first report public has been halted for
trading uninsured deposits right now
becoming a little bit less of the story
what's becoming a bit more of the story
is what's on your balance sheet what do
you invested in a lot of these Banks
hadn't invested in Risky assets it
wasn't like First Republic or even
Silicon Valley Bank was invested in a
lot of you know credit derivative swaps
and things like that weren't invested in
crypto and things like that they these
were a lot of treasuries mortgage-backed
Securities what happened was they had
taken huge losses because the Federal
Reserve had raised rates by at really
the fastest Pace in history when you
judge by how low rates were and how high
they are now this is the fastest rate
hiking cycle in history for the fed and
that cuts into the value of those bonds
and so it's safe things like
mortgage-backed Securities and
treasuries become unsafe because you
lose value and a lot of these Banks
weren't writing that value down and so
as they had to take on more cash to hold
up and pay for the and give money back
to their customers because again all
those deposits are known by the bank
they're owned by their customers their
liabilities meaning that the bank has to
give them back if customers want them
and customers will come and saying hey
give me my money back that means the
bank had to come up with the money for
those losses they'd suffered in the
market from the treasuries and
mortgage-backed securities things like
that but now we're shifting into a new
phase where I think there's going to be
more worry about hey what do you own are
you invested in any risky stuff are you
hedging
are you properly covering your risk
because that was what wasn't happening
at Silicon Valley Bank and I think the
fact that uh First Republic did not have
a plan in place before they reported an
earnings loss of a hundred billion
dollars in deposits well that suggests
that maybe they weren't doing their due
diligence as Bankers as well and that I
think is going to be the question for
investors are you doing your due
diligence are you insuring your deposits
are you doing and taking the steps
necessary so you don't suffer a bunch of
big losses that I think segues us
perfectly into what you need to be
watching for the rest of this week
because we have a Fed meeting ladies and
gentlemen coming up later this week the
fomc is meeting on Tuesday and Wednesday
of this week that's tomorrow and the day
after we will hear from Fed chair Jerome
Powell on Wednesday fed widely expected
to raise rates by 25 basis points that's
basically priced in a hike for May is
almost completely priced in for the
market what we don't know is what the
Federal Reserve is going to say at that
meeting what's Fed chair Jerome Powell
going to tell us what's he going to say
at the press conference and what's that
statement that they put out at two
o'clock P.M Eastern Time on Wednesday
going to say about how the FED is
viewing the market how they view this
latest failure in collapse of First
Republic in light of the overall banking
sector in terms of banks taking on more
borrowing from the fed and all of that
so I want to put something up here on
your screen next right here and just so
we can talk about what's happening in
the markets now as we look out at the
markets is the U.S treasury yield curve
and that shows us how much bonds are
yielding right now as you see on the
left side of your screen there that's
one month to six months to one year now
A treasury yield curve is supposed to
look basically the opposite of this it's
kind of it's generally either a straight
line or something like a Nike Swoosh
where if you're loaning the government
money because that's what these treasury
bonds are they're loans to the
government well if think about loaning
someone money if I tell you I'm going to
pay you back this hundred dollars you
loan me in a month you'd say okay well
you know maybe give me a dollar maybe
give me two dollars just to make up for
my time but if I say okay well I'm gonna
I'm gonna get this hundred dollars from
you I'm gonna pay you back in 30 years
or you're probably like whoa whoa 30
years I don't know what's going to
happen in 30 years you got to make it
worth my while you're gonna pay me five
ten bucks you know for that that's
usually what happens so as the further
you get out on the curve the higher
interest payments usually are the
opposite is happening right now because
there's fear in the markets
and there's the expectation that the
Federal Reserve is going to keep raising
rates and so you see one month two
months three four six months all around
that five percent level going from two
months to about six months and then one
year you start to get lower down that's
because there's worry about recession
there's worry oh maybe these things
won't get paid but there's also worry
that the Federal Reserve is going to
start cutting rates they're going to
keep rates high in the interim in the
short term and then start cutting and
that's a lot of what you're seeing in
that yield curve so that what you're
seeing right there that chart
illustrating expectations for what the
Federal Reserve is going to do next
folks expect that they'll keep rates
high for a little while maybe a month
maybe two months and then start cutting
them down and that we're likely headed
into a recession which is going to force
the FED to lower rates significantly and
that's why you're seeing those lower
rates longer term so what the FED does
at its next meeting is all the way
priced in we have also seen a
significant loosening of financial
conditions meaning stock price is higher
the s p is about 8.6 percent year to
date the NASDAQ of about 16 year to date
and it hit its highest since September
of 2022 uh just last week uh you're also
seeing bond yields down as you saw that
10-year yield which is the most traded
treasury really one of the lowest there
is uh in terms of what you're getting
paid for holding that and we will see
how that continues because that loosens
Financial conditions makes it cheaper to
borrow money makes companies more able
to go out and issue stock at higher
prices those things make it able for
make it so that companies are able to
participate in financial markets and get
money and the FED wants to slow all that
down that's at least their goal so that
meeting coming up on May or sorry coming
up on Wednesday you're going to want to
watch that now next the jobs report is
coming out this Friday but before we get
the jobs report we will get some very
interesting data on the jobs and jobs
and the labor market we will hear from
and I guess we're going to hear from
we're going to get reports on the jolts
report the job opening and layover
turnover survey and and we will get the
Challenger job cut report both coming
out this week now I want to put a chart
up here on your screen that shows you
the latest of what we've seen in terms
of the jolts number and here's what the
Federal Reserve has been watching Fed
chair Jerome Powell has been pounding
the table saying that the labor market
is out of whack what you see there is
there are about two job openings for
every unemployed person there's about 10
million job openings a little less than
that and there's only about 6 million
unemployed people so what you have is a
is a disconnect between folks looking
for jobs and folks looking for employees
there's a lot more people looking for
employees and there are people looking
for jobs that means you have to pay more
means inflation keeps pushing higher
because wages can keep pushing higher
when employees know that there's a lot
of job openings and not a lot of demand
in terms of a lot of people looking for
those jobs well they can say Hey listen
you want to hire me I'm going to take an
extra 20 more than what I'm making at my
current job that's and I'm gonna need a
big bonus and things like that
and these companies because they know
they're having to compete they're having
to pay that so this chart just
illustrating the kind of out of whack
state of the labor market the FED has
pointed to that they haven't really
talked about corporate earnings which
are record highs right now or have been
at record highs over the past few
quarters they've pointed to the labor
market and they've said we need to see
this come back into check before we're
going to be able to stop raising rates
or start cutting rates now the other
side of this coin the other side of the
labor market is another chart I want to
put up here on your screen and that is
the Challenger job Cuts report and
that's showing that layoffs are starting
to pick back up we are seeing over the
course of the first three months this
year January February March uh over
three or sorry over 400 percent increase
from March of the previous year now
that's still these low these layoff
levels are still at low at a low level
historically but compared to where they
have been we are seeing a significant
pickup ever since November of last year
or I guess since November this chart
just illustrating how that number is
picked up and how layoffs have started
to grow and you're going to want to
watch that report out this week last but
not least earnings reports listen we get
the biggest U.S company out this week
reporting earnings Apple that is always
a barometer for the health of the
consumer how much are people going out
and spending on those high priced Apple
products that definitely gives you
something to keep in mind in terms of
how well the economy is going Berkshire
Hathaway they own a lot of companies
like apple how have they been doing how
has their portfolio looked you'll want
to watch out Warren Buffett he's always
got something to say and we'll hear from
that company this week Bud light's
parent a b inbev they're going to be
coming out with earnings this week
there's been a lot of talk about Bud
light's partnership or its highlighting
or spotlighting of its partnership or an
agreement with a trans influencer did
that really hurt the bottom line well
we're gonna see you know men lie women
like money never lies Numbers Never Lie
I should say money sometimes that we'll
see but Numbers Never Lie and we will
get the numbers on a b and Bev this week
gas company Shell Conoco Phillips BP
those are all going to talk about the
consumer demand for energy there's been
a lot of questions about that and
that'll give us an impact on how much
are people driving but when you're
driving you're also delivering how much
of those earnings move this week we will
find out all about all those Airbus
that's another U.S company always I'm
sorry another company always well
trafficked and highly watched because of
what that says about the demand for air
travel U.S companies buy a lot of Airbus
planes and that's going to tell us how
confident these airlines are looking
forward and moving forward also big Tech
favorites AMD and Qualcomm also report
this week you are going to want to watch
those and that's going to do it for this
week on Market takes I'll know you could
have been anywhere in the world but
you're here with me and I appreciate
that I am Dion rabone reporter at the
Wall Street Journal we will catch you on
Market takes on Wednesday at the fomc
meeting 4 P.M be there or be a
that's a square don't do it that's going
to do it for us we'll see you on wind on
Wednesday 4 P.M Eastern right here on
the next Market takes